hey guys Ryan right here I'm gonna be
watching the trailer today for a movie
called Danny Collins reason why some
people not a lot but some people have
been Mike this guy likes every [ __ ]
trailer here's the thing anything I
watch it's because that has been really
requested and the reason most people are
requesting those is because the trailer
looks pretty damn good or the video
looks pretty [ __ ] awesome right no
one has requested Danny Collins but I
heard it's an Al Pacino Jennifer Garner
movie and I like both those actors I
especially like Al Pacino cuz even
nowadays how he's not the greatest I
hear he's still a great stage actor but
even nowadays he's still always fun to
watch like when DeNiro doesn't give a
[ __ ] cuz I'm gonna compare De Niro
Pacino like everyone else like when De
Niro doesn't give a [ __ ] about what he's
in he's pretty [ __ ] boring the watch
well now Pacino knows he's in a shitty
movie he's at least connect he like
really Al Pacino hang it up hamming it
up you know hooah
tonight you and I are gonna make love at
the worst Al Pacino I've done Pacino
Marathon and De Niro marathon and then I
will watch Heat Righteous Kill was a
shitty [ __ ] movie Jennifer Garner
she's good to look at man she's [ __ ]
cute she's pretty ah what it would be
like to be Ben Affleck penis for a day
so how could I intentionally not like
this trailer I mean we're all I know it
could be [ __ ] awesome it's rated R
for language drug use and some nudity
girls can change the trans dance
it'll surprise a guy at my age you give
me a heart attack if you remember in an
interview when you were a kid chai
magazine right like Lenin man John read
it and in 1971 can you believe it
dude Danny Collins stay true to yourself
stay true to your music my phone number
is below we can discuss this joke I
haven't written a song in 30 years I
haven't a breakdown I'm broken ain't
nothing left to break what would have
happened if I got that letter when I was
supposed to come I canceled the rest of
the tour I need to play Jersey I see so
you're staying indefinitely here are you
in drugs currently or in general
currently no good you're asking me to
dinner I think so I'm gonna have to
decline an unfriending curlier in
general you know but we have good
pattern I'm meeting someone for the
first time well you you look slightly
ridiculous to be easy reading your grown
son for the first time hello why are you
here
I'm just making some changes in my life
in a few minutes my husband's gonna walk
through that door and this will be the
last time I ever see you may have every
right to be angry I don't care enough to
be angry okay
nice to meet you have a good life this
family can be messy but you shouldn't
give up I agree tomorrow good night then
you're nervous
yes I've spent my entire life trying to
become the man that you alright thank
you sir I don't need you to say anything
man I just need you to leave you're
gonna have to deal with it because you
you never give up some dinners are worth
fighting for
fine well that's great
yeah it's for whatever it's another
[ __ ] traitor that's awesome okay like
some people might disagree on like Al
Pacino make needing to come back you
know like in my opinion I think like he
could go for a comeback and this looks
like this can put him back on top I love
Crazy Stupid Love that was it was wild
it was idiotic and it had a great heart
see I did know she looks great in it he
looks like he's having a good time and
he looks really invested in the
character you know like he's such a
natural and he he's like an every
[ __ ] moment and I love that about his
performances you know Jennifer Garner I
don't think is you know quite the talent
to live up to Pacino but she's so good
she's like I said she's not bad to look
at I forgot the guy who plays Al
Pacino's son
I forgot his name but I've seen a lot of
stuff I I know that he was co-star the
miniseries kingpin and he's been a lot
of Adam Sandler movies forgot his name
but he's always fun to watch he's always
great to watch and he you know he does
look enough like a Pacino in my opinion
but know this movie looks really
heartwarming it looks really moving you
know it looks like the kind of movie
that's gonna tug at your heart put a
smile on your face you know there might
be some like obvious messages in cliches
but whatever I mean it looks like a fun
journey where you know you might you
know if you put your [ __ ] guard down
and you just enjoy goddamn flick you
might notice you've removed in a
positive way doesn't always have to be
some sad [ __ ] um looks fantastic when
that movie comes out I'm totally gonna
review it that is a
be worth reviewing anyway guys if you
know to the channel you can subscribe I
thought my lamb Gabriel out there Ryan I
want to know the girls of all your
videos what are of you sisters or
something friends all of the girls live
with you well Gabriel if I'm gonna
answer this question I'm gonna answer it
with pure confidence and because you
know truth is conviction in a lot of
ways so here's how I do it
hookers they're all hookers Laurens a
hooker Alyssa's a hooker Samantha's a
hooker Brandy's a hooker
Mariza hooker no one buys her but she's
a hooker
Sally's definitely a hooker and even my
girlfriend Veronica's a hooker ya know
ah should not call your girlfriend a
hooker that's why I clarified Veronica
that is not a hooker she is a damn good
Christian follower
Logan Lawson hey I love your videos a
shout-out would be awesome my youtube is
Logan's man gave thanks and keep up the
good work well Logan Lawson you should
subscribe to Logan's mancave
Logan's mancave as a channel I'm very
familiar with it's a vlog channel and
you basically it's called Logan's
mancave because you basically see Logan
and his mancave and he vlogs about it
you know you can see Logan play guitar
you know see is awesome talent and music
and then you can you know watch him
smoke weed see how good he is he can
even blow the smoke rings you know
that's really hard to do and then you
can watch him jerk off desequerah his
favorite porn star he's really into
asian girls Matthew Martinez hey ray
pretty sure you met Ryan I was looking
for the Mortal Kombat X trailer and saw
you reacting to it and you were funny
and I started watching your other videos
and one of the videos I saw Alyssa be
crazy Wow
I would really appreciate a shout out
for me but also her thanks man keep
making me laugh and keep her on the
videos Matthew Martinez Elissa is not
here she is working the streets right
now and I'm not apologizing for that
that one's staying yeah this is not here
I like to go in the order because I
don't like it's hard to just I don't
want to make another list of people I
gotta say that's just too much work for
me
that is like an extra five minutes out
of my day not gonna do it but Matthew
sure I can give you one still Matthew
Martinez mm-hmm let's see what can I
work off here Mortal Kombat X and we
could talk about violence and sex and
see how that links the Matthew Martinez
Matthew let's see Matthew Matthew
McConaughey's or McConaughey joke here
or Matthew Matthew from the Bible
Matthew Mark Luke and John maybe he
knows the other three and that could be
funny Martinez he could be Mexican
Matthew Martinez the Spanish Bible
version that's where we go with that's
where you got your name from Spanish
Bible Matthew Martinez Luke and John
Garcia